[Music]  hello neighbor  hey I'm Fred Rogers in here  it's a beautiful day in this  neighborhood a beautiful day for a  neighbor would you be mine could you be  mine  please won't you be my neighbor hello  neighbor mr. Rogers I'm here to  interview you it is so nice to meet you  okay hold filing mr. Rogers would please  don't ruin my childhood this piece will  be for an issue about heroes do you  consider yourself a hero we are trying  to get the world positive ways of  dealing with it feelings  yeah like what  you know many things you can do  you can play all the lowest keys on a  piano at the same time  [Music]  you love broken people  like me  sometimes we have to ask for help and  that's okay  I think the best thing we can do is to  let people know  [Music]  that each one of them is breakfast  hey mr. Rogers it's a beautiful day per  neighbor  please watch me that was wonderful  you